in this capsule goodbye the concept
of the value of a plan we saw the
definition of a mdp our processes of
peace on marc orian it requires the
definition of the whole heap of
action that can be taken from
different states of transition model
which determines us the probity to arrive
in mind state if one is a state s and
that we perform an action at and finally
a reward function as we who
determines the reward that there I
hold back if it reaches you also
given the definition of a plan then this is
simply a set of decisions that
specifies each and
what is the action that followed
the action has therefore that corresponds to do
a request to the plan worse for you have
current so that does not specify the actions
who are followed by an agent when
follows the plan and then data
now what we would like is for
evaluate the quality of a plan for
eventually say that or develop
algorithms to maximize this
value there so and intuitively we
would like the value of a plan to be
basically correspond to the sum
rewards that we accumulate if we
follows a plan that gave so let's see
more formally how do we
can set the value of a dish then
for a plan worse data and a state where
the money is sold our tv of
pi s as being the value of a plan worse
do you have and this value there actually
it will match the rewards
accumulated average to average because
that there is uncertainty in our
environment
so we're going to have to average a sphere
hope on what could happen
to integrate our certainty about what
what could happen after
running in the dish so that's going to be
the accumulated rewards if we follow a
full udder
and that we start at the state is this so
finally me often write that way
recurring yves then vépy two aces
the sum of two things the first
thing this is the present reward if I
find me the state s
I'm going to make an air reward of s
I will add to that the others
rewards coming
after the state s I did an action
given that I'm going to a state that
share in a spirit state even and because
that v de pie ix this game defines them as
being the sum of the rewards from
of a state is this good if I want to know
what is the sum from the state s
I can link him to vic the sum of
future rewards market from the
roofs and this premium or express that would be
a vise that I will have reached after having
been in the state is this so in this
recursive definition the man but are
the sum of rewards accumulate I the
breaks down into the present reward and
the future rewards where he is this is the
sum of future rewards that
corresponds to v2 and s premium now
because there is uncertainty from
of a state is this if I am my plan
so I take the action pi 2s
so that's going to match the action that
I take to the state is this if I am the
given peak plan there is some
probability that I reach anywhere
what and todd expresses as a whole
of all grand s so what I do
it is that I will hope for
this future value of the parades and the
sum of future rewards so I do
with an average hope for all
the following states expresses possible
weighted by the probability that
I reach that spirit state mla from
of
when I am my plan would give so
if what this expression the
correspondence makes the sum especially the
minds even possible from value to this
once I reach it expresses my
weighted by the probability that
I arrived this bonus
if from rs I do the action that
s now there is another term here
that I have not explained what is
call the second factor
so that's a factor that normally
is between 0 and 1
we need that factor because
as I explained in a capsule
previous normally we suppose that
the agent life infinitely in
the environment then finally no but
end of action so it helps to
represent the body or an age where one
do not really know the number of actions
that the agent will do or that can
also match a species
evaluation if you have an agent who
invests in the stock market and so they
want jacket then the agent in question
final computer equipment
infinite and we want to know took a
very very large number of action towards which
then is our policy
our agent will converge however if
the rewards are all positive
although I made a name for a movie
of action i'm going to get a reward
cumulative that will be infinite so I
must be introduced a term that must
to be smaller than one who is I can
actually demonstrate that if I do that so
if my kid here strictly smaller
than at a bath I had to have a
sum of rewards that will converge
who will not be infinite and his
intuitively too we can see
as representing the fact that precisely
with an agent who had style in the
money purse that I get the day
even who would be my present reward
worth a little more than money
i would get it later would not it
because that money there can win in
value by the money that got more
early in the future so intimate
we can see it a little like that then
if not from a mathematical point of view
it's to control the fact that in fact
if we have a man is finished with action he
must have some
seconds on future rewards
hope for not having a sum that
finished now that we defined the value
let's see how with this value there
we can compare different plans
firstly we will say that a plan that
will dominate another full prime
if we have the following two conditions
first is that value then is it
so vépy is this your biggest of
treat could have been prime is this for all
states but in addition it will exist
at least one state is such that the value
at this state is this your strictly
bigger for the plan worse than for
my other pip plan
so we go in this case that foot in
does its value is always at worst equal
to the value associated api prime except for
- a state where we will have a value
strictly more serious
so that's why we're going to say that the
plan will dominate the plan that will dominate
the other plan that premium and now we
will say that a plan that would be optimal
a plan that is dominated by no other
plan so in fact with this definition
there could be several plans
optimal but all these plans are going in
does have exactly the same value and
that we could have two plans that
are incomparable that is to say that
none will dominate each other so that wants
to say that in fact the dominance based on
plan values ​​will induce a
order function but only partial
between plans this being said it's not
really a problem because we
will be interested in actually found the plan
optimal and therefore platinum at the time
it goes forward either one or
many but he'll always have to
less an optimal plan and how
resell there are two algorithms
different iterations by value
evaluated creation and iteration by
political or not so very young who will
allow us to find this plan
optimal before seeing his algorithms
we will see how can we
characterize the value of a block
buildings wherever they are
the equations of the requests that we
gives a condition that is guaranteed
to be true for optimal plans
specifically for the value of these
plants immo the equations 2010 that for
a final plan it's going their victory to
the state is this vote is equal to the
reward to pieces the most the maximum
about the actions that I can take at
the state is actually I would have belonged
sizes 2 6 6 2 so the maximum on
the actions of the sum of the rewards
future hope to associate with the action
given ok so mark if it's not
exactly the same as before at 20
in the equation associated with the definition
recursive value to places of lodges
who you are with and therefore what it is
says here is that in a plane
optimal
the action here is the action that goes
so maximize the action that is being flouted
for the timal plan would be the action
who would maximize that sum of
future rewards was hoping so so that
means that if we are able to
calculate to find v stars we would
able to get the plant imams the plan
said massa would be just for each
and it corresponds to finding the action
which maximizes the sum of rewards
future and hope they have justice
so the gamma here that is constant by
relation to so if we can ignore it
would simply maximize that
expression there here
and if we had kept watch so we
could do this maximization there and
that would allow us to get the plan
optima so that's equations
of Germany that will come when we go
talk about the algorithms that will attempt
to find a little evil white
for a decision process mark
come back give